[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de gauche à droite bien vos contenus
j'ai juste djindjic me fut cathy xavier
héry deux couples d'amis parents
d'enfants en situation de handicap
depuis de nombreuses années je suis
administratrice au sein de la givre la
givre est une association parentale qui
gère onze établissements dans le
beaujolais allant de la petite enfance à
un âge avancé
cathy et la présidente adjointe de cette
association
notre histoire commence il ya quatre ans
nous avions pour habitude
katie et moi le mercredi matin d'aller
faire de la marche nordique dans notre
club caladois
c'était l'occasion pour nous d'échanger
sur notre quotidien et de parler de nos
préoccupations avec nos filles en effet
pauline la fille de katie et xavier ne
verbalise pas par contre elle grogne
elle grimace pour nous exprimer qu'elle
en a assez d'avoir ses parents et sa
soeur sur son dos salomé
quant à elle voulait faire comme tout le
monde
sortir le samedi après midi avec ses
copines aller se promener dans
villefranche sur saône pour faire du
shopping et puis s'installer en terrasse
pour boire des cafés
oui mais voilà quand on a 17 ans et
qu'on en paris 12
quand on ne sait ni lire ni écrire et
que parfois on se trouve submerger par
ses émotions
c'est pas facile de faire que de faire
comme tout le monde
est ce que vous en pensez je me souviens
de ce mercredi matin hivernale un soleil
magnifique nous montions ch mignon
cheminon tout doucement sur la montée de
l'avé maria
ou plutôt de la madone un signe avec
katy nous avons eu l'idée
l'idée toutes les deux de monter un café
un café associatif ou les personnes en
situation de handicap serait accueilli
bénévoles dans un espace chaleureux et
bienveillant à notre connaissance cet
espace n'existait pas alors nous avons
fait jouer la solidarité associative
c'est à dire que nous avons rencontré
andré leprêtre qui est la présidente de
l'association la givre nous lui avons
présenté notre projet tout de suite elle
a adhéré
elle nous a dit allez-y foncez ça
n'existe pas vous pouvez le faire
on était rassuré et puis nous sommes
allés rencontrer xavier brideau xavier
brideau et le directeur de la résidence
l'accueil une résidence située en plein
centre de villefranche nous lui avons
soumis notre projet est lui aussi nous a
soutenus et il nous a même proposé de
mettre à notre disposition un snack
toutes équipées en plein centre de
villefranche et tout ça gracieusement à
ce moment de l'histoire où seuls 5
lucie la soeur de pauline a rejoint
l'équipe et nous sommes motivés
déterminés unis pour commencer
l'aventuré calade access qu'elle a
d'access pas une philosophie sa
philosophie petit en l'épanouissement de
la personne accueillie et de ses
accompagnants petit 2 la libre
expression de chacun et enfin petit roi
faire vivre un espace un lieu échangés
où on pratique plutôt les changes et la
parole librement au sein au sein d'un
quartier
pour cela nous avons imaginé un concept
un espace un café dans un seul lieu
mais avec trois différents temps de café
le café associatif fonctionne sur la
base du volontariat
plutôt du bénévolat mais c'est à dire
que nous avons une petite équipe de
bénévoles des personnes en situation de
handicap et des personnes ordinaires qui
arrivent le matin de 10 heures à 18
heures le café associatif est ouvert un
samedi par mois tous les 3e samedi de
chaque mois
notre équipe de bénévoles mixte va
installer préparer la salle pour
accueillir nos clients de 10 heures à 11
heures et ensuite interviendra de 17 18
heures pour le nettoyage et la remise en
place de la faim à partir de 11h nos
clients arrivent à ce moment là c'est le
cas c'est le café culturel à travers des
ateliers proposés aux personnes que nous
accueillons des personnes en situation
de handicap ont la possibilité de
s'essayer sur des temps de cuisine sur
des temps de relaxation sur détente de
bien-être des changes demande à l' un
des ateliers favori de notre café
culturel et puis après on passe à un
moment de repas bhl ce sont les
bénévoles de l'association qui vont
vendre les préparations culinaires que
nous avons fait pendant l'atelier
le café des aidants est un espace de
rencontre de parole et d'écouté pour les
familles les accompagnants et les
proches
il permet d'échanger sur des thèmes
abordés tels que le dossier mdph vivre
avec une personne en situation de
handicap ou bien encore préparer ses
vacances des sujets abordés
naturellement et qui convienne à tout le
monde ça c'est vincent excusez-moi j'ai
beaucoup d'émotion donc je me perds un
peu avec mon petit appareil allez je te
prends des défis les défis ce sont nos
amis nos amis qui sont présents à côté
de nous et qui porte les couleurs de
calais d'access alors les défis ça
permet effectivement de faire connaître
notre association à travers des
manifestations sportives mais aussi
culturelles comme aujourd'hui
et puis les défis c'est aussi l'occasion
pour xavier qui n'a pas pu venir
aujourd'hui de faire du sport et de se
lancer dans des challenges un peu fou du
style vtt alors je crois qu'il a fait la
saintélyon il a monté le mont ventoux
enfin bon on le suit on est à fond avec
lui et avec tous nos amis
alors dans ce café ont ce café
associatif vous allez me dire et les
clients les clients ils n'ont pas pu
être là aujourd'hui
sauf une nathalie et je la remercie
elle et ses parents d'être présent et
d'être venus me soutenir
merci nathalie les clients ils ont
plaisir à revenir et je sais qu'ils sont
présents
les 3e samedi de chaque mois les
familles les familles ont plaisir elle
aussi à se retrouver à échanger à rompre
un peu parfois la solitude elle
participe elle aussi aux ateliers
elles le sont même certaines pour l
animatrice de ces ateliers est bien
évidemment elle consomme alors tout
n'est pas si simple
effectivement nous rencontrons des
difficultés comme accueillir de nouveaux
types de handicap ou bien le temps le
temps nous manque le café associatif et
la préparation des ateliers chronophage
mais que deux victoires
aujourd'hui je peux vous dire que depuis
trois ans que le café existe
le rêve est devenu réalité nous sommes
toujours présents
comme les cinq doigts de la main nous
sommes toujours ensemble
après des kilomètres de sandwichs et des
montagnes de gratin de coquillettes
nous sommes toujours là alors qu'elle a
d'access c'est 38 café 7 café des
aidants huit défis enfin presque puisque
le huitième est en train de se dérouler
mais c'est aussi calade access pour moi
quand je repense à tous ces moments
partagés
un grand moment de joie
un grand moment de plaisir d'amusement
et d'inspiration des petites bulles de
bonheur qui font que sur le chemin de
nos vies parfois un peu
long compliqué notre paille plus léger
quand mon ami français tu m'a demandé de
participer à cette énigme
je lui ai dit qu'elle est le sujet la
résilience la résilience hockey boris
cyrulnik
mais encore je ne sais pas si notre café
associatif rentrer dans la définition de
la résilience
ce que je sais c'est que nous ne pouvons
pas imaginer l'avenir de nos enfants
mais nous pouvons anticiper en leur
proposant de nouvelles expériences
est-ce que la résilience à vous de juger
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]